I've had people that find out I'm a
stripper and they're just like how do
you do that with and be a mom and but
I'm like I just a my mom what do you do
when you go to work someone who works in
the ER and they're they see things that
children shouldn't see that doesn't
affect their children right it might
affect them and I'm sure we deal with
stuff that affects us on a personal
level but you put it together like every
other parent and you do your parenting
duties and you come home and you kiss
boo-boos and you cuddle
[Music]
my name is Lexi I'm 26 years old and I'm
a stripper so I was in kind of a
financial bind
I was out a lot of money it right after
I had my second baby and I needed a job
quick so I traded a baby carrier for a
pair of stripper heels literally to a
friend I auditioned at a club and I got
a job and I've been in love with it
since because I love the money I can
make I've never had a conflict morally
with parenting and dancing at all I got
pregnant with my daughter when I was 19
I had her when I was 20 and I just fell
in love with mothering I've homeschooled
her forever
being a mom is number one it's
everything and it's really it motivates
at all obviously I want to be able to
buy my kids Christmas presents and take
them to Disney World and you know just
do anything for them if my kid needed a
tutor or to go to a private school I
want to be able to do that and I feel
like it really improves my kids quality
of life you money gives you opportunity
I don't care what people say about
happiness but it gives you opportunity
and that's really important for me
Christmas is always a big holiday I make
family vacations in Disneyland and
Christmas a really big deal and it's
it's really how I know how to express to
my kids that I love them and I want them
to have something magical like memories
I want them to feel loved I want them to
remember a big beautiful tree and
presence
[Music]
when my family has ever criticized what
I do or they're like I wish you wouldn't
do it they'll claim it's about my safety
but I told them that if you really want
me to be safe what you do in your
everyday life is don't let people make
jokes about strippers don't let people
talk about us like we're not human
beings or you know when you hear that a
stripper has been murdered don't let
other people say oh you know she's kind
of asking for it don't make excuses for
our humanization and our violence you
know I mean that's what's gonna make us
safe overall it's by changing how people
view us I have definitely experienced
being outside spending time with people
and them just assuming that's I'm a
dancer that I'm more sexual or I'm gonna
do something for them or I just really
like it I just really want to take my
clothes off for them or something but
the first night I ever danced I was
assaulted like I had a guy tried to put
a dollar bill inside of me while I was
on stage that's how he thought he was
gonna tip me like I said like jokes and
stuff like that contributes to people
feeling like we want it it's cool it's
what it is you know as opposed to this
is a pay-to-play situation and every
girl has different boundary is my
daughter knows that I dance she knows
that I work at a club she knows that I
go on stage and do tricks on a pole when
she asks why she can't come and see me
work I tell her it's because they serve
alcohol so it's not for children she has
no concept of a lap dance or anything
like that I like to be open because I'm
not ashamed and I want her to know I
don't want her to be embarrassed I want
her to hear from me you know what I do
and what's going on so that if one day
somebody's like your mom is a stripper
she's like yeah she's athletic she's
beautiful she's confident she's
hard-working my mom's a stripper for
sure
[Music]
it's just about providing for them it's
just about giving them the life I think
they deserve which was everything and
more as I be able to get them more I
want them also to understand that other
people don't have that and it's a hard
work that it takes and let that be the
perspective the lens that they see it
through
[Music]